we're asked to graph f of x is equal to
the natural log of 2x and i'll use a
calculator here to find a table of
values for different x values what is f
of x equals but then i'll hand draw the
graph which might be a little bit ironic
because i'll be using a graphing
calculator to come up with the values
but i won't use the graphing function to
graph it we'll do that part by hand so
let's try a little table of values of x
values and of y values and see what we
get so these are my x values and let's
say y is equal to f of x so whatever the
output is i'm going to set that equal to
our dependent variable and plot it on
the vertical axis and we call that
dependent variable y
so let's try some really small
numbers so actually first let's remind
ourselves what's the domain what's the
set of valid inputs for x that we could
put in right there so the natural
logarithm is just logarithm base e
and any logarithm it's only defined it's
only defined when the input into the
logarithm in this case 2x is greater
than zero you can't even take the
logarithm of zero you could raise
something to a very negative exponent
negative billionth power it'll get
pretty close to zero but you could never
get it to zero if you take a positive
base there's no exponent you can raise
it to to get to a to get to 0 or to get
it to a negative number so this 2x right
here the input into our logarithm
function in this case the natural
logarithm function it has to be greater
than 0. if that's greater than zero
divide both sides by two that means x is
greater than zero so that is essentially
the constraint the constraint on our
domain our domain is all real numbers
greater than zero
so let's try some let's try some that
are pretty close to zero just so that we
get see what happens the behavior as we
approach as we as we're close to zero
and especially as the input here is less
than one
so let's try
let's try i'll just try
0.1 let's try
0.5
let's try see what happens when we get
to 1 and let's try
i don't know let's try
oh i don't actually i don't want to go
too far because i i want to be able to
see the resolution down here so let's
try 1
1.5
and let's try
three
let's try three so those will be our
inputs that we'll try actually let me
try well yeah that sounds good enough
and then let me
draw my axes and then we'll plot the
points so our domain is positive x
values so we don't have to draw we don't
really have to draw much on the negative
x values but we will have some negative
values here so let me give ourselves
some room to work with and our x values
go up to three so this is
one
two
and three this is point five one point
five
and then this is two point five which we
do not use and then let's see what our y
values our f of x's are going to be
equal to so get out our ti-85
so if we take the natural log and
remember we have to take 2 times x and
then the natural log of that so if we
take the natural log of 2
times
0.1 which is obviously 0.2 what do we
get
we get negative
1.61 i'll say
negative 1.61
and then if we input 0.5 what do we get
get the calculator back so we we're
going to take the natural log of
2 times 0.5 we could do that in our
heads that's 2 times 0.5 so actually
i'll just write it out just so it's
clear what we're doing 2 times 0.5
that's the natural log of 1. and you
should be able to do that in your head
what power do you have to raise any
positive base 2 to get to 1. when you
raise it to the 0th power you get one
and there you go you raise it e to the
zero power you get one
so this right over here should have been
able to do that one in our heads now
let's do the next one
what happens
when our it's the natural log
the natural log of
2 times
2 times 1 which is obviously just going
to be 2 so it's the natural log of 2
gets us 0.69 which makes sense that this
is less than 1 because 2 is less than e
e is 2.71 and so on and so forth so this
is 0.69 so this is
0.69
now let's try the natural log of 1 of 2
times 1.5
natural log of 2 times 1.5 which is
really just the natural log of 3.
and that gets us to 1.0
well i'll just call it 1.10 i'll round
to the hundredths so this is
1.10 and then finally the natural log
natural log
if i take the natural log of 2 times 3
2 times 3 2 times x x is 3.
what do i get this is just going to be
the natural log of 6 which is
1.79 so this is going to be there's a
new color
this is going to be
1.79 so in terms of the coordinates
we've gone as low as negative 1.6 as
high as 1.79
so let's call this
let's call this right over here
negative let's call this negative one
negative one and then we're down here
would be negative two i'll extend the
y-axis down a little bit
so this is the x-axis this is our y is
equal to f of x axis and then let's call
this right over here positive one and
this over here is positive two and this
would be halfway between those just
because it looks like we're going to
have to be able to see that as well
and so this first point is point one
negative one point six one
so point one that's one tenth that's
gonna be right around there and then we
have negative one point six one so
negative one point six one is going to
sit right about
and 0.1 is going to be even further to
the left so it's going to be right about
there
right about there so that is the point
0.1 and negative 1.61
fair enough that's that first point
right there
now let's do this one point five comma
zero
when x is point five y is zero that's
that's zero point five
comma zero fair enough
then when x is equal to 1 y is 0.69 when
x is equal to 1
y is 0.69 which might be right about
there just approximating it's a little
bit closer to 1 than it is to 0.5
actually a little bit closer to 0.5 than
it is to 1. so maybe let me
put it right over there so this would be
the point this would be 1 comma 0.69
and then we have the point
we have 1.5 when x is 1.5 f of x is 1.1
when
x is 1.5 f of x is 1.1 which sticks us
right about there
so that is the point i see i think you
see where this curve is going
1.5 comma 1.10
and then finally so that was that point
we'll do this last one in yellow when x
is 3 y is 1.79 when x is 3 y is
1.79 so a little bit closer to 2 than
1.5 so it's going to be right about
there
it's going to be the coordinate 3
1.79 and now we can connect the dots and
i'll do that in white
and so it's going to as we go as we get
x values that are closer and closer and
closer to zero our graph of our function
is going to get more and more and more
negative it's and it's going to get
closer and closer to the y axis without
ever touching it so it's just going to
get closer and closer to the y-axis
slowly break away
slowly break away and then curve out
like this
curve out
curve out just like that and just keep
on going it'll keep on going down like
this and what happens over here is
pretty cool where as x gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller the the
function gets more and more it becomes
infinitely negative as x approaches zero
but x can never be zero there's no power
that you can raise e or any positive
base two to actually get zero you can
raise it to a very large x negative
exponent you can get if you raise e to
the negative
one billion
negative one billion you'll get a number
that's very close to 0 because this is
the same thing as 1 over e to the 1
billion power 1 billionth power
so this is a number that's very close to
0 but you're never going to approach 0.
you can make this number more and more
and more negative and you'll get smaller
and smaller smaller smaller numbers but
you'll never quite you'll never quite
approach zero so you can never have a
logarithm you can never have a logarithm
of zero here so you just approach it but
we're done this is the graph of the
natural log of 2x it has that typical
because this is really just a logarithm
it has the shape of a logarithmic graph